Hi Amy!
-Hi
Danke,
dass du dir Zeit für uns nimmst!
Warst du schon einmal
in einer Online-Talkshow?
Ich denke schon, aber ich
habe ein schlechtes Gedächtnis
Ich gebe viele Interviews,
also gehe ich davon aus.
Wie ist die Lage?
Es läuft ziemlich gut!
Ich war im Urlaub,
weil ich Geburtstag hatte.
Ab heute arbeite ich wieder.
Es ist cool wieder
in Deutschland zu sein.
Alles Gute nachträglich!
Du bist sehr berühmt in Deutschland
Ist das im Rest Europas anders?
Ich glaube,
ich habe mehr Erfolg in Deutschland
bin aber sehr glücklich auch in
anderen Ländern erfolgreich zu sein
wie zum Beispiel Österreich Spanien
der Schweiz, Frankreich und England
Ich habe sehr viel Glück gehabt und
bin dankbar für die Unterstützung.
Überrascht dich der Erfolg noch?
Ja! Das ist etwas,
von dem ich immer geträumt habe.
Ich wollte es immer, aber in
dieser Branche weiß man nie
wie sich die Dinge entwickeln.
Ich bin immer überrascht,
aber auch sehr glücklich und
aufgeregt, wenn es gut läuft!
Dachtest du schon als Kind, dass
dir das einmal passieren könnte?
Nein, denn wie gesagt, in dieser
Branche weiß man nie. wie sich die
Dinge entwickeln werden. Ich habe
davon geträumt, das eines Tages
tun zu können, aber wissen konnte
ich das nie! Das war ein Schock!
Das war ein Schock?
-ja! Der ganze Beruf ist ein Schock
Immer noch?
-absolut! 100%!
Du machst jetzt eine große Tour
durch Deutschland; spielst in den
00:01:46.000,00:00:49.000
größten Hallen des Landes!
Schockiert dich das auch?
Eher aufregend als schockierend,
da ich mir das erarbeitet habe!
Die letzten Konzerte, die ich
in Deutschland gespielt habe
waren in großen Hallen! Am nächsten
Tag habe ich dann auf einem Platz
gespielt. Das ist sehr aufregend!
Ich freue mich sehr auf diese Tour!
Was ist das für ein Gefühl vor so
einer Masse an Leute zu spielen?
Das ist einfach
unbeschreiblich aufregend!
Ich meine, es gibt so viele
Menschen die nur davon träumen
und ich kann es tun!
Dafür bin ich sehr dankbar.
Ich bin sehr aufgeregt da raus zu
gehen und vor meinen Fans zu singen
Was denkst du, wo dich deine
Karriere noch hinführen wird?
Ich weiß es nicht; wie gesagt:
in diesem Geschäft weiß
man nicht was morgen ist!
Ich weiß nicht was in den nächsten
Jahren passiert, aber wenn ich
weiterhin die Möglichkeit habe das
hier zu machen werde ich werde
ich glücklich sein, weil das hier
etwas ist, was ich sehr genieße!
Und was sagen deine Freunde dazu?
Die sind sehr stolz.
Genau wie meine Familie.
Die waren von Anfang an da
und sind sehr stolz, dass es
für mich so gut gelaufen ist.
Sie haben mich immer unterstützt.
Wie viel Zeit hast du für sie?
Ich gehe sicher,
dass ich mir Zeit nehme.
Sie sind der wichtigste
Teil meines Lebens!
Ich nehme mir die Zeit wenn ich zu
Hause bin jeden zu sehen der anruft
Aber ist das möglich wenn
du auf Tour bist?
Man kommt ja danach nach Hause,
Eine Tour dauert ja nicht ewig.
Ich wollte es ja so. Ich habe
nach der Tour Zeit für sie.
Das funktioniert ganz gut
und ich habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Wenn du dann nach Hause kommst,
bist du dann nicht erst erschöpft?
Ja total! Immer wenn ich zu Hause
bin ruhe ich mich erstmal aus,
gucke Fernsehen und
stehe nicht oft auf.
Es ist schön seinen eigenen Platz
wieder zu haben und zu entspannen.
Ok. Wir wünschen dir viel
Glück bei der Tour
und Erfolg für die
nächsten Jahrzehnte!
Danke!
- vielen Dank!